over the past 24 hours we've been just
overwhelmed by your response to our red
state trailblazers town hall
in orlando last night now we had five
gop governors
who joined us for a wide ranging
conversation about how they
grown their economies how they've
protected individual freedoms
and how they've beaten back the radical
leftists dominating the democrat party
now none of them had waited for
washington's permission to open their
businesses
or lift their mask mandates or frankly
get their students back in the classroom
and none of them are cowed by the woke
mob
blm or the gender fluidity crowd
they're all happy warriors one thing all
the ceos told me they could not operate
in california they came to the city of
texas because they knew
it was great for their employees great
for their workers
great for the staff but great for their
vision of what they wanted to achieve as
a business
we just need to encourage people to step
up do the right thing
and um and and fight back it's worth
fighting we have to fight back but we're
fighting back in florida so i'm gonna
the bill's passed i'm gonna sign a bill
that will hold big tech accountable
it'll allow you to sue big tech if they
censor you or to platform you
and also provides protections for
political candidate speech
now contrast that with the democrats
very
dark vision of america tonight
i come to talk about crisis the worst
pandemic in a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
nice cars lined up for miles
waiting for a box of food to be put in
their trunk more than 400
000 schools and child care centers
have pipes with lead in them wow
so uplifting it's shocking that more
people didn't tune in for such an
inspiring message we have to come
together
to root out systemic racism in our
criminal justice system
we have a real chance to root out
systemic racism
that plagues america and american lives
in other ways
plagues american life the governors of
florida and texas two of our
most diverse states beg to differ it's a
bunch of
horse manure i mean give me a break this
country
uh has had more opportunity for more
people
than any country in the history of the
world and it doesn't matter where you
trace your ancestry from
use race to divide and then attack each
other
and it's wrong texas is a land of
opportunity for absolutely
everybody and we want to unite everybody
not divide people
today's democrat party is so left it's
left america
it tolerates mass illegal immigration it
coddles criminals
looters rioters and it seeks to silence
any and all opposition from law-abiding
citizens
just look at what they did to senators
tim scott on twitter this week
i guess they thought they were being
cute with their uncle tim hashtag
but really what they did is they just
revealed once again
how sick twisted and anti-american
they've become
it seems like the many people in the
democrat party and it's not just the far
left as many people in the democratic
party
are putting down america day in and day
out it's almost as if they they want to
act as if
there is not this thing called the
american dream and they are
absolutely wrong the truth is today's
democrats
despise our political system they hate
the way most americans live
and they revile our history and our
traditions
so when biden talks about creating
opportunity
he's just talking about the opportunity
for big government
to grow bigger by taking more of your
money and more of your freedoms
but for the gop governors opportunity
means
job creation in the private sector one
that is freed from the heavy yoke and
high taxes
and endless red tape texas is the
ranks number one in the nation for black
owned
business job creation for black
women-owned business job creation for
hispanic-owned business job creation for
hispanic entrepreneurs
and in order to become job creators and
entrepreneurs that governor abbott was
talking about well
kids have to be in school they have to
be learning they have to be playing
sports having a normal life
americans also just need to be together
not shut away from one another
at least that's what the republicans
fought for remember when
uh president biden got on the air and
said we want everybody to be playing
you know uh sports again i'm like we
were doing that last summer yeah what is
he talking about we want everybody to
gather it fourth of july
uh we were doing that last summer too
he's like
completely out of touch with what's
going on in our states he does not know
what's going on
we warned you a year ago that democrats
would seek to use the pandemic
to keep us in a continual crisis mode
then of course that crisis of the
pandemic just falls into the next crisis
the systemic racism crisis the climate
crisis
you know hawaii just declared a climate
emergency this happened yesterday
so these perpetually hyped crises are
then just used to justify the left's
brazen efforts
to take more of our money and more of
our liberty that's how the game always
goes
but the only real crisis that america
suffers from today
are those that are created by them the
democrats like the border crisis
or the education crisis or the crisis of
rising crime
so if texas and florida and the other
red states had followed
new york and california's lead a year
ago think about it america's economy
would be in the dumps just like europe's
this is a headline out of germany today
where they're implementing once again
more pandemic restrictions meanwhile
our first quarter real gdp number that
just came out
6.4 growth that is truly astounding
and of course biden is trying to claim
credit is all his doing
but he deserves exactly zero credit for
today's booming economy
it was all the doing of donald j trump
the red state governors and the american
people who rejected the doomsdayers
and stuck with first principles they
trusted their own
constituents over the so-called experts
who just wanted us massed up and
afraid for as long as possible so if
biden had been
president think about this just a year
ago if he had been president
all of america would look like michigan
failing miserable and pessimistic
let's not forget how they saw this whole
thing unfolding
about a year ago this time they were
saying that we might not recover
from this pandemic economically for
decades
but what the story of the past year
really reveals
is that americans can't be held down or
held back by washington for very long
yeah the democrats won the election by
selling biden as a nice kind of moderate
democrat
but now now the voters are beginning to
see what they really got
they got an elderly hostage to the far
left
they've gone from obama's yes we can to
bidens
yes we're racist this deeply cynical
view means that democrats can only
occupy america they can't really govern
it
what a depressing world they want to
foist on us
but my friends optimism beats pessimism
any day of the week
and by next year a lot of those suburban
women who voted for biden
they're going to think this doom and
gloom social distancing act of the
democrats
has gotten really old and they're going
to be looking for a brighter vision
i think greg and kim and all these
governors are doing it right
and we will have a resurgence of freedom
in this country
and 2022 i think is going to be a great
year for us
last night we saw what a pro-american
government looks like at the state level
it was all about joy success
love of country and freedom hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else